لم تهتز عزيمتهم محمد رسول الله ظلوا
متمسكين باداء واجبهم
يا الله يا الله يا الله المرضى المرضى
المرضى يا الله قرب على الطفل
صور اخرى تكمل المشهد هنا لا صوت فيها لكن
صرخات الهاربين تكاد تسمع منها
مرت ايام على تلك الاوقات المرعبه التي
سجلتها كاميرات المراقبه في هذا المستشفى
للدقائق الاولى من كارثه الزلزال لحظات
الرعب الاولى تلك عاشها الجميع هنا اطباء
ومرضى وما زالت تلك المشاعر مستمره مع
تداعيات الكارثه
ليست مشاعر فحسب
هناك من ترك الزلزال نزوبا في اجسادهم
وحياتهم
هناك ضخم يعني تعلو صوت احمد اصوات
الاجهزه الطبيه المحيطه به
بصعوبه رولنا قصته
[موسيقى]
وقتلت العائله
في ماساه اخرى نجت ارين الطفله وقتلت
العائله
لم يبقى لها سوى دنيا
عمتها ستتولى رعايتها بعد الان
والله ما بعرف شو بدي احكي
يعني خرب بيتنا
ايش صار ما بعرف والله العظيم انا
بده يصير باهلي شو بده يصير ما بعرف والله
العظيم
لكل جريح هنا قصه ماساه وان وجع
فاطمه وجرح اخرون يتولى مداواتهم اطباء
عاشوا دقائق الكارثه ولما يغادر المستشفى
منذ وقوعها
اموركم كادر الموجود يعني يعالج الجرحى
بنفس الوقت عم يفكر باهله اللي هم بالبيت
انه ترى
وقع البيت عليهم وقعت البنايه عليهم فصار
كمان هو عايش هذا التناقض بين انه انا بدي
اروح اشوف اهلي انقذهم ولا انا بدي اتعالى
اتعامل مع الجرحى
بين الام الجرحى في المستشفيات ومعاناه
المشردين في الخيام
يتمسك من نجى بامال تجاوز تداعيات الكارثه
الدنيا كلها بس ما بدنا شي
عمر حلبي الجزيره
ريف عفريت
والله ما بعرف
الله يفرجها احسن شيء